my name is David Peterson and I'm the
language creator from HBO's Game of
Thrones this is my process for creating
a language very first thing you need to
do is figure out why you're doing it
who's going to be using the language is
it going to be human beings because if
it's not going to be human beings then
you have to talk about you know
different vocal apparatus in other words
is this gonna be a language that's
spoken or is it going to be a language
that's signed you go and see oh actually
by the way the people that are gonna be
using this language are these aliens and
they have one big eyeball they don't
have a mouth they don't have any ears
and they have a bunch of tentacles it's
an entirely different process like what
can they do well they can see so it's
probably going to be a visual language
what can they use they've got their
tentacles so they can use their
tentacles to make a sign language that's
kind of like the process you need to go
through at the very very beginning after
figuring out whether your language is
going to be only spoken or spoken and
written then you can move on to sounds
the sounds that exist in the various
languages that we speak are ordered
consonants are separated into their
manner that is how they're produced and
then the place in the mouth where they
are produced so you can create like a
little table
let's do Dothraki right now that's easy
stops fricatives nasals and talks myths
which is a catch-all term for like
basically everything else and then what
comes next is the place of articulation
where you pronounce this stuff in your
mouth
so there's labial sounds coronal that's
when your tongue tip touches either your
teeth or the bump behind your teeth
there's velar uvular glottal and you can
fill out the rest of the sounds so
starting with the lips Authority doesn't
have any stops it does have F and V
nasals M what that means is that you're
doing something in here but the air is
actually passing through your nose yet
though Finley and Finley's for
approximate it almost makes contact but
doesn't quite so it's not you know but
it's Wow
T and D s and z and Dothraki you also
have this sound and then for approximate
so we kind of got these guys and this
one that looks like a regular R that's a
nice trill
I have no tricks for helping you
pronounce that you just gotta practice
it I feel bad about that one but the
idea is that you fill out this chart and
what you notice is that things are
occurring in groups the idea is that you
don't want to have too many sounds but
you have enough so that words can sound
different enough without having to get
too long
I would then do a different map for
vowels but it kind of works the same
they're either front or central or back
and that's where your entire tongue body
is the front valves are things like e
the back valves are things like ah and
the central vowel sound really really
like when you're making your syllable
shape this is part of how you give your
language a character deciding exactly
how the syllables are going to shape up
what consonant clusters you're going to
allow or not allow in Dothraki
there are plenty of consonants including
the consonants W and Q how we I think it
actually means bile when you turn this
into the object of a sentence the usual
thing that you do is you drop this vowel
but you cannot endure a key and a word
with these two consonants it's simply
impossible so you insert a dummy eval
just so that it's pronounceable and
that's part of what shapes the character
of Dothraki you know that you're never
ever ever going to see a word that ends
in either of these sounds it just can
never happen syllables are so important
because you're trying to give the
language a sound if it could be that any
word could fit into the language then
what does it sound like it sounds like
anything if you're creating a language
for a show that's what you want them to
get the sense of that they can actually
hear a word and say no that doesn't that
sound like a dothraki word order me may
throw that one sounds weird you want
them to be able to say that even if they
don't know why or how when it comes to
stress and intonation and also tone you
have to decide alright is this Lee was
gonna be a stress language or is it
gonna be at own language so English is a
stress language that is we have stresses
placed in various places hello other
languages like Hausa or Mandarin are
tone languages that is the actual pitch
that you speak the the Vallot is
important we saw I've done both I do
syllable mostly because I am not
convinced that actors will pull off a
tone language correctly when you're
designing a stress language there are
rules to where certain things are
stressed so for something like Dothraki
it subverts the expectations I guess of
English speakers this word obviously
English speakers are gonna look at that
and say well Dothraki yeah
simple enough in Dothraki that word that
syllable is stress so it's Dothraki
Dothraki to be honest the stress rules
are pretty easy once you get used to
them so I just remember eyes them
next is grammar and grammar is something
that we can refer to as morphology
that's how words relate to one another
and set themselves into paradigms every
single language on the planet that we
know of makes a distinction between
nouns and verbs basically having nouns
versus verbs as far as we know is the
most important distinction in language
when you're creating nouns the thing
that you have to decide is what is going
to happen with these nouns do I want to
have singular and plural do I want to
have a dual or a trial number exactly
two or three or something do I want to
have nothing do I want to have case and
if so which cases how many the last
thing is gender the gender just refers
to what type the noun is that can be
masculine and feminine but it could also
be big versus large living versus
nonliving natural versus non natural
tool versus plant that's
something that you can decide as you're
building the language in high Valyrian
nouns have four numbers 8 cases and 4
genders so you have to know a lot of
stuff to be able to use a noun in high
valyrian but you don't have to use a
whole bunch of extra words like little
prepositions and stuff it means you have
to use fewer words and your sentences
can be shorter that's how it works
verbs are the most important part of any
language and it's also the part that I
hate creating the most the verb is the
engine of the entire grammar they can
have tense they can change depending on
who the subject is or who the object is
or who the indirect object is there are
also other parts of speech that some
languages will have there are adjectives
adverbs can come in three different
types there's manner adverbs time
adverbs place adverbs
there's also prepositions plenty of
languages have little bits that come
afterwards that are just like
prepositions and they're called
postpositions
japanese has postpositions so as high
valyrian determiners are little words
that give you a more specificity about
the now demonstratives give you a little
bit more local information in Dothraki
there's actually three different ones
there's this close to you there's that
close to the person you're talking to
and then there's that way over there
that's close to nobody nouns verbs and
all of those extra parts all of that
together is what comprises the grammar
when it comes to sentence structure the
first thing that you have to do is
figure out what the order of the major
elements in your sentence is going to be
for example the sentence the man sees
the woman it's the subject first then
the verb sees and then the object is the
woman so the man sees the woman in high
valyrian sal it'll different you start
with the subject again voila that's the
man and then you put the object already
okay and that's the woman and then
finally the verb or Venus sees its
subject-object-verb after you decide on
your basic word order four basic
sentences then you have to move on to
other types of sentences for example
questions so voila
pretty old Ernest is the man sees the
woman but if you want to turn that into
a question
Valar Briones
does the man see the woman you don't
actually change the word order you don't
add at another word in high Valyrian you
just change the intonation when you're
creating the language this is your way
to demonstrate exactly how your language
works differently from English it's
really cool to come up with a really
cool and like fun and interesting and
quirky grammar but if every single thing
is just word for word exactly as English
is right in a row then you haven't
really done anything very interesting
the next step would be derivation we
have for example the verb teach and we
have teacher one obviously came after
the other that is what's known as
derivation and you can do that with your
language as well and it's probably a
good idea to give you an example in high
Valyrian there is a word jade meal the
enemy o is the word for wind but then
when it came time to come up with a word
for storm yeah I could have made a brand
new word you can obviously see that
they're not related in English there's
wind and storm but I thought I ought to
be fun to actually make this word a
derivation of another word so I started
with jennie-o which is the word for wind
and so from Jimmy o we get Jim asthma
JAL MASMA is like a big wind or a great
wind and that is the word that's used
for storm and then this is how I
actually made Daenerys his last name Yin
Maz mo Jen Maz mo is kind of like of the
storm and that's how you get the idea of
Daenerys Stormborn up next or
miscellaneous categories one of the
things that of course you'll have to
eventually run into when it comes to
creating a language is the number system
first is the number system going to be
base 10 or not in English there's a big
stop kind of like a ten then at 20 then
30 and 40 and 50 and so on not all
languages are like that for example if
you have a base 8 number system what is
written 1 2 is not actually 12 in fact
it is 10 when you're creating a writing
system a unique writing system for your
language you get to decide all right is
this thing going to be an alphabet and
abjad a syllabary like an abugida
or is it going to be
something that's more glyph base like a
logograph e in an alphabet you have
unique characters for vowels and
consonants in an objet characters for
consonants and that's it in something
like an abugida
you have a main glyph for a consonant
and then some sort of a little addition
for a vowel and then in a logograph e
you will have glyphs that stand for
entire words or parts of words or maybe
more than one word depending on exactly
how it works the last step to creating a
new language is the lexicon the lexicon
is all of the words of the language bear
in mind that a language like you know
English or French or German languages
like these have thousands upon thousands
of words my largest language Dothraki
has 4,000 words and i put a lot of work
into it it takes a long long time to
create thousands upon thousands of words
so basically when it comes to the
lexicon when you're to that point you're
gonna be working on the language for the
rest of your life but yeah it's a lot of
fun you can really start wherever you
want think about say for example a
scenario writing a horse
starting a fire and think about what
goes into that scenario what's happening
and what will the speaker's of this
language have words for with respect to
that scenario there are so many
possibilities in front of you you can
just spend days doing this everything
that I create goes into a full reference
grammar and dictionary document
everything is written down so that if
somebody else needed to figure this out
they could figure it out if you want to
make your own language and you want to
get really good at it certainly you can
study linguistics you can also study
many other languages but when you study
languages don't study related languages
so it's it's cool to study French and
Italian in Spanish it's better for you
as a language creator to study French
and Japanese and Turkish languages that
are totally unrelated this is going to
help give you a much better idea of
exactly how languages can be
I have a favorite word in anything in
anything and any languages I've created
or any of the languages that study if
you want to know an interesting word
though and it doesn't matter what the
language is look up the word for
butterfly they always have really really
weird and bizarre etymologies it never
fails